Kobe never left anything on the court.
And I think that's what he would want for us to do.
No one knows how much time we have.
That's why we must live in the moment, we must enjoy the moment.
We must reach and see and spend as much time as we can with our families and friends...
...and the people that we absolutely love.
To live in the moment means to enjoy each and everyone that we come in contact with.
When Kobe Bryant died, a piece of me died.
And as I look in this arena and across the globe, a piece of  of you died...
...or else you wouldn't be here.
Those are the memories that we have to live with and we learn from.
I promise you from this day forward, I will live with the memories that knowing...
...that I had a little brother that I tried to help in every way I could.
Please, rest in peace, little brother.